Chris where you from I'm from New York
Oh kiss you both anymore originally from
queens new york and original growing up
as a kid I wanted to be a rapper I think
like most kids in my neighborhood I
wanted to be an MC and it was kind of
chasing that passion that got me closer
to filmmaking because i went to audio
school graduating from there and i have
the knowledge of being a recording
engineer but then after going out into
the field I kind of felt I wouldn't say
kind of I thought contained by what I
was able to do with the knowledge that I
had acquired from being a recording
engineer with where I was as far as our
creative person and I thought I found
myself in a crossroads where the music
wasn't enough and i ended up that's what
started writing and started out writing
short films and started out just writing
letters to my son and believe it or not
before he was born I was just writing
letters to him about things that I had
learned in life and I tried to write it
in a way that will be entertaining to a
young kid reading it and then that kind
of just gravitated into me telling like
life learning stories you know and then
that kind of kept evolving any before i
knew i was writing my first screenplay
and you know about 12 years later now
I'm hooked well i'm from the i'm from i
was born in on Honduras I'm actually
Spanish I'm born in honduras and I came
I came over head it's New York in 1987
so I think I was like six seven years
old at the time but yeah lived in
Brooklyn New York and Brooklyn I came
over here but I ever ever since I was a
kid I was into martial arts martial art
films and action films and but I never
thought of thought of myself as being
active total trying to trying to trying
to hack I was going to this fight yes
compete and I see what it takes me until
I came to Los and
met him and s and he'll he'll never say
it but I'm going to say a form he's
really really good so he's not going to
say it himself he can do really
spectacular things if you look at the
redemption short film you'll see them
kind of climbing dilled the telephone
poles and jumping off of buildings and
doing flips off of cars and that's just
the beginning for us so we're still
learning what we can do together what
you know what we can do on film and on
camera to entertain so you know really
excited about the prospects for are the
two of us in the future so from what
you've learned of the film and acting
world what are the similarities to the
music industry and also fighting that
you take into pursuing this new venture
to me is for the similarities to music
is to me it's very similar it's a the
passion still has to be there the work
ethic and the dedication still has to be
there the attention to detail to me in
my years as a making music and writing
screenplays to me I find that everything
has a formula no matter what you're
doing in a it might not be a formula
that fits for everyone but everyone can
come to their own formula on how they
can create something and see their way
from beginning to end all the way
through and I found a lot of
similarities between filmmaking and
music because i think the beats of a
screenplay are very similar to the beats
in music you know you have your kick
your hi-hat your snare your snare and
they have to relate may have to have a
rhythm that works with each other but
then they also have to work with the
baseline and actually things that you
add on top and to me those are character
relationships those are different
characters that interact with each other
and now they have different conflicts
and all little things jive and they
create a rhythm and after a while when I
write and if I prepare enough my
characters my situation and my setting
and everything the story starts to speak
to me and tell me what to write yeah
it's so to me up fighting basically at
the dr dedication because you're going
to get a lot of bumps and get them in
the film
people didn't tell you I just your film
stocks your horror but it's in there so
you got to have thick skin that's all so
well in fighting you know I mean so I
learned it from fighting also being in
front of the camera fighting so I take
their four-month my competing days I
still compete now and put that also in
film that's on me and I'm also jailed in
a way because he's also former boxer and
I'm a kickboxer so we kind of put there
together and we take everything from
experience if someone doesn't have thick
skin can they learn it get through
getting knocked down in this business if
you have the determination you have
there aren't any heart and it's yeah the
one or the other if you're determined
enough you developed a thick skin
because you won't give up so then
eventually the skin comes with it you
get harder with it you know I think I
used to you know crude criticism used to
be a hard thing as a young child to
accept but you know as I kept going up
and kept going up i began to search and
look for it because I good or bad you
can learn from it you know and I I first
for that criticism because with it you
get better and in anything you do so
yeah I think you need both but you can't
survive with one for a while but
eventually you'll develop the other if
you got too thick-skinned and hopefully
you put it down and get the
determination but I think that's the
termination is number one
you